[Music]
now a lot of people they look at the
news these days and they think the big
news stories today are will the new al
Qaeda underwear bomb threat or where
President Obama stands on gay marriage
people think those are the big stories
well judging by local news there's an
even bigger story that is sweeping the
nation right now here's a look at
today's real top story Thank You Don
well we watch them on YouTube and post
their pictures on Facebook what is it
time for dogs to have a social network
of their own who is it time for dogs to
have a social network of their own is it
time for dogs to have a social network
of their own is it time for dogs to have
their own social network of their own is
it time for dogs to have a social
network of their own is it time for dogs
to have a social is the time for dog to
have a social network of their own is it
time for the goal
their own social network at the time for
dogs to have a special social networking
site of their own visit time for dogs to
have a social network of their own is a
time for dogs to have a social network
of the ride the time for dogs to have a
social network of their own if it time
for dogs to have a singing network of
their own it's a time for dogs to have a
social network of their own is it time
for dogs to have a social network of
their home is the time for dogs to have
a social network of their own is it time
for dogs to have a social network of
their own is it time for our dogs to
have a social networking side of their
own is it time for dog dam a social
network of their own is it time for dogs
to have a social network of their own
this is time for dogs to have a social
network of their own good question
[Music]
that's depressing my favorite are the
people that look like they just like
went to the grocery store and then did
the news yeah they're not even dressed
up never wandered in did he sure it'll
do